jetzt
[Musik]
sehr bedeutend herzen kommt zu einem
video das ist schon seit ewigkeiten
machen wollte ihr freut euch
wahrscheinlich was er zum kopf gerade im
sport oft wird ein ganzer erklärung wir
machen heute die ultimative ninja
parcours challenge und zwar sind wir zu
diesem zweck im jump haus in köln ihr
uns freundlicherweise hereingelassen
link dazu wissen der bestrahlung steckt
die auch in farbe schaut mal vorbei wenn
ihr aus der nähe von köln kommt kommt
mit heute die sache ist ganz einfach wir
haben hier spielen die so genannten
jobboxen tempo sie besteht aus drei
verschiedenen lanes einmal eine einfache
wie eine etwas schwierigere und dann
richtig schwierige und diese der bahn
wenn du heute durchlaufen guck mal der
schnellste ist aber ich glaube ich erst
mal die leute vor die wand laufen
da haben wir ein erster stelle hier an
den affen gesagt dass du da bist was ich
gerade bei fix machen welt ins gesicht
getreten
dann haben wir jana die verrückte
prinzessin
ja was soll man dazu noch sagen dann
haben wir sie die pumpe rennen und ja
dann wenn er noch ich kleine rot also
wir haben insgesamt drei bahnen das hier
ist die erste bahn hätten also patel
über die man balanciert dann da hinten
hat man so ein paar schaukeln und
balanciert noch eine schaukel sondern
zwei schaumstoff säcke
ich glaube ich nicht dann haben wir die
zweite bahn die schon soll ich mir am
anfang so eine rolle die drähte ich
nicht aber dieses mal dann hat man
irgendwo gelochte scheiben die in der
luft hängen an die man sich in die lang
hangeln muss wer die aus diesen mega
mega leicht kann gestalten sollen
dahinter sind noch verringern zum
hangeln dahinter ist noch eine leicht
wenn der luft und noch ne leiter also
das ist schon deutlich schwieriger
und dann haben wir hier waren drei den
absoluten kick parcours so der anfang
ist noch okay glaube ist und dann hier
ist aber so der punkt erreicht man
einfach nur noch komplett frei hängt von
diesen tafeln dass man hier so stangen
in der luft hängen und da hinten hängt
also einem balken in der luft noch mal
standen dran und er würde mich wundern
wenn wir das schaffen
ach ja ganz kurz nach ich lag gestern
noch mit schüttelfrost im bett also ich
sollte das wirklich nicht machen leute
bevor wir anfangs noch ganz kurz wir
haben drei bahnen der erste auf ihre
band liegt vier punkte der zweite 3 der
dritte 2 der letzte einen mann bekommt
man sich schafft und dann rechnen wir
zusammen und der aus drei waren die
meisten punkte geholt hat der ist der
gewinner ab und dann mehrmals ins
gesicht schlagen genau und ja wir waren
dreimal verkauft dann geht man nur
punkte und darf es bei der nächsten
weitermachen politischen vier leute
verfängt an
[Musik]
oh ja da ist die pleite des staates
müssen vor teilt bogdani an let's go
[Musik]
ok jetzt hinten kommt kommt dieser schau
doch sagte er ist mehr als willig und
erscheint drin zu sein und wir haben die
zeit
schlecht meinte so nicht darunter
und jetzt ein zweiter kandidat für die
erste bahn die verrückte prinzessin jana
exner und verläuft über die
sind felder ganz entspannt dann ist ob
wir wissen wie die stelle her da wartet
schon ein bisschen da hinten über die
machen wir keine schaukeln jetzt die
schaumstoff säcke ich glaub ich werd ich
schwierig und jetzt ist sie glauben ab
der matte und wir haben die zeit die
zeit es 38 sekunden
aber jana der männer sich gekehrt
los geht's
[Musik]
wirklich
sieben teilnehmerinnen sorgen
selbst der video performance auf den
plattformen schaukeln auch gut genommen
erzählt sich auf jeden fall ich bin hier
sind ballast okay so jetzt schon jetzt
schon auf dem ersten schaumstoff sagt
kommt der zweite
und da ist ja der matte um ja eine zeit
von 30 sekunden
und ja ich habe mir die ergebnisse jan
hat sich mit der kraft eines
südasiatischen schimpansen auf platz
eins gehandelt 20-25 ein sorry 30 3 und
jana 38 und kanal mit am tisch
das heißt vier punkte vor jahren drei
für mich zweifel sowie ein trojaner okay
leute das heißt jetzt zweiter parcours
januar fängt wieder an ok ja dann bitte
deinen versorgt
beim bayerisch vertreten diesen
komischen kers schreiben
wer das tut wird die ja okay das macht
halt findet wieder der alltag
leiter der mann hatte von den kleinen
leitern der geruch zu klettern
und wenn meine zeit 40 sekunden für
fogna
diesen folgen
es gibt vermutlich aber ganz gut
gemeistert kann man diese käsescheiben
[Musik]
apple hat heute 5
kaum ging probiert
schaffst du nicht schaffen
von jetzt an nicht länger den ring
sondern direkt weiter direkt an den
nächsten ring ja in allen klassen
bisschen schwing mit den wahlen für ok
jahres wird der versuch startet jetzt
seltsamerweise von der zweiten plattform
bieten mal schauen ob sie ist in der
zeit von einer landschaft dort wo vor
[Musik]
keine angst haben schnell hoch ist wie
das rechte bein mehr möglich
mein für das recht das recht einfach
jetzt gehören als gebraucht dann ganz
entspannten dahinter geleistet und jetzt
haben wir eine zeit 49 20 gute zeit oder
für den ganzen umfang kurzer zeit ja
[Musik]
doch
der blick wie beim einfahren ein papier
[Musik]
ganz kurz bevor du anfängst ich habe
gerade eben bei jana ein fehler
beobachtet und zwar hatte die nicht die
richtige positive einstellung deswegen
hatte sie probleme an den ring wird gern
sehen dass du bist ein positiver an die
sache rangeht dann klappt das auch okay
ist als co
[Musik]
ja
jetzt
[Musik]
der 4
görlich
[Musik]
berufen
wirklich irgend aktion stabil und wir
haben zeit eine minute 8 und 9 sekunden
hier noch mal die übersicht der zeiten
jan hat hier ganz entspannt den bananen
modus aktiviert 41 4 geholt sebastian
leider 49 9 dafür warum und ob indiana
49 sekunden für den zweiten teil und
sowie für den gesamten park 18 4 3 2 1
[Musik]
das von fiat
das ist einfach
damit ordentlich jetzt nach unten
drunter durch eine dabei nicht die
beiden kommen lassen das schon heavy
tyres ist er weg
und wir haben eine zeit 38 6 und finde
ich glaube ja wohl das geht doch
[Gelächter]
und weiter schön mit den armen
[Musik]
es war okay schlecht
ja er
[Musik]
nein wir gar nicht so schlecht ist so
gut halten
den begriff ich hab für spritzige finger
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fachleute jan 38 58 wirklich aber geht
ja nein oder 1 und von mir keine zeit
verdrücken trainer seinen augen für in
diesem moment drei leute und jack
unbedingt hier drin noch eine neue folge
was das geht ab